وسائل اعلام روسيه صورا قالت انها لمحققين
تابعين للجنه للجنه المكلفه بالتحقيق في
الهجوم الذي تعرض له جسر القرن اليوم
واظهرت الصور المحققين وهم يجمعون اجزاء
متناثره على الارض من اجل فحصها وكشف
ملابسات الحادث
من جهتها اعلنت لجنه التحقيقات الروسيه
مقتل مدنيين واصابه طفله في الهجوم على
جسر القرن واكدت اللجنه ان الهيئات
الامنيه الاوكرانيه هي من تقف وراء هذا
الهجوم
وفقا لمعطيات لجنه التحقيقات ففي ليله
الماضيه تضرر جزء من جسر القرن نتيجه عمل
ارهابي نفدته الهيئات الامنيه الاوكرانيه
الخاصه وبسبب هذا الحادث لقيا مدنيان
حتفهما رجل وامراه وذلك خلال عبورهما على
متن السياره فيما اصيبت ابنتهما بجروح في
اطار القضيه الجنائيه حددت الاجراءات
الضروريه للوقوف على الاشخاص الذين يقفون
وراء تنظيم وتنفيذ هذه الجريمه في صفوف
الهيئات الامنيه الاوكرانيه الخاصه
وتشكيله المسلحه